il est adorable et enjouée santiago rêve
de devenir policier comme chase dans la
pac patrouille et partir comme son héros
à la rescousse des gens mais à quatre
ans seulement il est en train de perdre
la vue c'est vraiment dur à voir ça
parce que la témoin on si on pourrait on
peut on voulait donner à nos yeux pour à
lui
[Musique]
santiago est atteint de la vie trio
rétinopathie exsudative familiale une
maladie extrêmement rare aussi appelé
fever elle provoque le détachement de la
rétine de l'oeil chez l'enfant
le diagnostic est tombé en début d'année
après trois ans d'investigations la
première médecine qui a vu son terreau
il ya donnait déjà un prescription pour
seul on est mais aucune marche très bien
construire des lego est déjà plus
difficile pour san diego il ne pourra
jamais devenir policier comme son héros
chase mais pour ces parents leurs
enfants a le coeur de super héros bien
plus grands que ceux à la télé je te
vois comment il est
il est vraiment gentil avec 17 enfants
et vous toujours rêver ses soeurs tu
vois la façon qui il voit la vie pour
moi c'est les patients actuellement la
maladie fever ne guérit pas les
traitements actuels ne permettent que de
ralentir sa progression
techniquement beaucoup récent gala
rétinopathie du prématuré qui elle est
une maladie plus fréquentes mais il ya
de l'espoir
assure le médecin spécialiste ici à
sainte justine en plusieurs équipes de
recherche qui sont spécialisés dans
cette pathologie et tant qu'il ya des
avancements
qui sont prometteurs pour les années à
venir
renata échanges auraient toutes les
raisons du monde de se plaindre de leurs
années 2020 j'ai perdu mon job
ça fait juste quand même chemin que j'ai
commencé un nouveau job
le contraire le couple en a profité pour
se rapprocher et savourer davantage les
petites bénédiction de la vie j'avais
comme peut-être c'est tout bêtement avec
ma famille ça c'est une autre chose que
kate est bon le courage de géants de
leur petit garçon les épate à chaque
jour mais j'ai voit comment ils essayent
de était une enfant
nomade livre il considère que c'est dans
l'adversité que le meilleur de chacun
d'entre nous se manifeste ici pascal
robidas radio canada montréal
[Musique]